what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with inferno yes our monthly
series which covers all the x-men stuff
and in this video we're actually going
to get some huge revelations in terms of
just what all's been going on here and
that not everything is what you expected
to be which is exactly what i expected
because it's jonathan hickman so here's
the thing
what this does is it goes all the way
back to the beginnings of krakowa now if
you guys recall cipher was just kind of
like the guy who seemingly believed in
charles xavier no matter what right that
cipher is the one that can basically
discern any alien language whatsoever
and the whole basis behind percoa is
that cocoa itself is what was
technically a mutant that merged with an
island but it's basically a living
island and that it made perfect sense as
far as charles xavier is concerned that
if the mutants were going to have their
own uh their own place to live their own
utopia essentially it should be an
island that is in effect a mutant and
that cipher would bridge the gap between
the island itself and the mutant
population essentially be able to
communicate with it on behalf of the
mutant population and turn it into the
utopia that they needed and so where
cipher didn't initially understand
everything that was going on xavier of
course basically gave him like a mental
image of what he imagined seeing and
then it was really up to cipher from
there to start building on it right to
start turning it into something now what
we also end up finding out here is that
along the way uh cypher doug had
basically brought in warlock now warlock
we've kind of talked about before but
we'll sort of rehash this to it you know
for a bit for people who are a little
unfamiliar with that or don't really
know who he is at all so warlock's a
long-standing member of the x-men
community and he's actually the
precursor to the phalanx right so what
you had here is basically a group called
the technarki uh and they were
essentially kind of like living
machinery now when warlock arrived on
earth that also coincided well really it
was actually a few years later but and
coincided with a guy named cameron hodge
the desire of cameron hodge who was
initially the benefactor of the original
x factor team is that he was he was so
anti-mutant that he actually took what
was in effect warlock and then tried to
merge him with human physiology and by
doing so created the phalanx race as we
know it but that's kind of how warlock
ties into those things now he's not
really a member of the feng likes
himself instead he's actually the son of
the king of the tech narc and basically
just fled because he didn't want to be
confined to that life or anything along
those lines but the the big thing here
the big important thing here is that
doug trusts warlock implicitly right he
trusts him absolutely and for good
reason like they've got a lot of history
together but one of the things that he
says and this is something that we
weren't even aware of is that when we
initially read this it was xavier
dropping off cipher and saying here you
go man turn this into something that'll
make the mutant nation proud and doug
was like i'll do everything i can
professor x and then you know professor
x left and that was basically it what we
end up getting is the other half of that
that doug never trusted professor xavier
he asked him like he says like so the
professor has plans tell me warlock do
you trust him and the response of
warlock is no self friend experience
says that we do not trust charles xavier
now that's an important thing to
understand here the x-men as they were
originally written by stan lee and jack
kirby and even in the early days of
chris claremont you look at giant size
x-men by by len wein there were
basically a lot of reasons to trust
xavier he was a bit of a creep because
like he had a crush on on jean grey
which is really kind of strange because
she's gotten older and he hasn't so you
really gotta gotta wonder why in the
world that works the way it does but the
thing about this is that uh professor x
really the the first major instance i
would say of the mutant population
distructing professor x and really more
the x-men than anything else i would say
was probably x-men deadly genesis that
was like a huge revelation when you
ended up finding out between the the
basically the defeat of the original
x-men team when krakow was first
introduced in marvel comics and like the
new team that he formed and i guess
giant side is actually number one by
lynn wine so like colossus will rain
storm all those characters coming
together for the first time but the
x-men deadly genesis story in the mid
2000s actually revealed that he had a
secret mutant team that nobody knew
about now that's not to say that he was
wholeheartedly trusted up into that
point there were a lot of instances when
xavier established the fact that either
he was a dick or because of his mental
state that he couldn't be trusted so
things like the onslaught saga were a
really big example in the sense that he
was so frustrated with humanity that
when he shut down the mind of magneto
magneto's hatred for humanity merged
with professor xavier's frustration with
humanity and formed the the onslaught
entity so we've seen multiple instances
over the years when xavier's done some
pretty nefarious stuff and so it makes
sense that even if they are kind of
going with the idea there is a little
bit of distrust there but we'll actually
find out just how far reaching this goes
because the first response that doug has
is okay we'll cross that bridge when we
get to it for right now we need to turn
this into something now following that
what you end up learning is that the
island of kokoa had in effect merged
with warlock and this was all done in
you know for an intended purpose what
that intended purpose is we'll find out
at a future point in time but it's one
of those things where doug kind of
having his secret conversations with or
i guess his personal conversations with
the island of krakowa was always asking
like how do you feel about the idea of
being turned into an island nation for
the mutant population then it turns into
how do you feel about like millions of
mutants living here different things
along those lines right that in a lot of
ways kokoa seemed to kind of go with it
but didn't necessarily seem to be a big
fan of it but it was one of those things
where it was really like warlock and
gracoa and cipher kind of working
together in secret so nobody would
really know exactly what it was that
they were doing now again the role
warlock plays will become very important
later on down the line but one of the
things to also know is that at the
outset the nature of krakowa is that in
order to sustain itself it has to feed
on life energy and that's one of the
reasons why krakow just kind of seemed
to go along with that is because as time
progresses what you would basically have
is all these mutants occupying this
place and instead of feeding on the the
life energies of like five mutants like
he did in the original giant size x-men
number one which i have which was
autographed for me by jonathan hickman
and i'll never get rid of uh that
instead it can feed on the life energies
of millions of mutants but it can still
sustain itself the same way so tiny
little bits of energy versus huge chunks
of energy so again it's kind of an
interesting thing but but of course doug
working directly with with cocoa and all
that kind of stuff ended up basically
creating the croco and gates which were
aware of they allowed the grecons or at
least the mutant population to pass from
one location to the next all that kind
of stuff but along the way all these
discussions that they have it always
kind of seems to be that they don't
necessarily trust professor x and all
this comes to a head when it turns into
what's basically the place where no
one's supposed to know about right the
place that moore and mctagger exists
kind of like a null space we're sort of
in krakowa but hidden away from kokoa
and not even krakow itself can see it
right in the sense that doug basically
says like this is going to create the
habitat that they requested the one that
nobody can gain access to here's the
kicker right he says like yukakoa will
not be able to see this they've
requested that what they don't know is
that warlock has basically merged with
you so while you can't see it warlock
can't so warlock will be our eyes and
ears on everything that's going on with
regards to this little secret habitat so
we can know what's happening and that's
when we end up finding out that doug
ramsey right and krakow and warlock all
basically know about maura mctaggart and
they know that destiny's back and they
know that maury mctaggart wants to kill
destiny and what this does is it
confirms the suspicions that doug ramsey
had that professor xavier and magneto
cannot be trusted while he doesn't seem
to know the exact ins and outs of what's
going on because they don't discuss
every single little nuance inside of
this little this little secret habitat
he has solidified enough to know they've
got some kind of secret plans that no
one's supposed to know about they could
in effect get the mutant population
killed potentially that's an important
thing here and so following that you
basically switch over to uh destiny and
mystique who have been summoned by emma
frost now this is a really really cool
encounter right because destiny died
long before the stepford cocoons were
ever introduced right they described
themselves as a singular entity split
into five parts and of course mystique
introduces them as five parts
representing a singular entity it's all
the same thing they're splitting hairs
at this point right as semantics right
like it's five plus two versus two plus
five it's all basically the same thing
and so as a result of that they kind of
try to establish their dominance here to
you know a little bit like no mystique
that's not what we represent this is
what we represent which is basically the
same thing you said just saying it a
different way and so destiny's like hmm
do you know who i am and they're like
yeah like your destiny they say you're
the most powerful clairvoyant mutant to
ever live and she's like yes do you know
what i see when i look into the eyes of
all five of you and their question is
what and she says i see two who will
find love three who will not one who
will be changed forever severed from the
five and other world itself and one of
you will never recover from it right
that was the nature of destiny she
always answered in riddles and one of
the things that the the step for kakuza
kind of put off is that destiny and
mystique can't possibly comprehend them
right because then at the end of the day
they kind of change who it is that wears
like this black outfit so they could
differentiate or at least the rest of
the world can differentiate between each
of them because the world just couldn't
tell the difference if they all were
white and so on and so forth and so when
the question is asked like well which
one of us is going to go through this
the response of destiny is like how
would i know there isn't any difference
between any of you you're all basically
the same right and then walks away and
it's one of those things where it's it's
not like super significant but it's
basically destiny busting the balls of
uh of the stepper cuckoos right the
stepper cakes are getting tested by
destiny
that's basically what it is busting
their balls to see how they react but
it's one of those those funny little
little moments here right because kind
of going into that the discussion that
takes place between emma frost mystique
and destiny is pretty significant here
and the reason why is because if you
guys recall at the end of the last video
we basically talked about how emma frost
was brought in by professor xavier and
magneto and given essentially the the
truth about everything that's been going
on but the fact that they'd held it from
her for so incredibly long despite the
fact that she's been a long-standing
member of the x-men community and that
if anybody on the council has earned the
trust to know what's going on that it
should have been her it felt like a
massive betrayal it felt like they just
didn't trust her and so at the end of
the day she just ended up storming off
she you know of course wasn't going to
blab their secrets to the world so she
wasn't going to work against them but
she wasn't going to work with them
either and that's what she establishes
here that she's very much on her own and
that's kind of how it's always been for
emma frost right she's always kind of
been on her own the only exception to
that is when she first encountered and
really began to lead generation x really
when she first created and then led
generation x up to that point in time
even when she was part of the hellfire
club she was very much alone she was
very much isolated just kind of a core
part of her character but what she
basically tells mystique and destiny is
that more mctaggart's alive and when
they initially reject the possibility
she gives them just what is in effect a
mental indication or a mental view of
one of more mctagger's lives remember
all that information was given to emma
frost by professor xavier so she can
pass it on to other people if she
chooses and so she basically shows
destiny and and mystique this is the
nature of more mctaggart as a mutant
right she is a mutant she is not human
she has the ability to die and then
resurrect and that in and of itself is
what makes her so powerful is she can
wipe away our timeline right all she has
to do is just die and then do something
different and our timeline doesn't exist
anymore now again this is marvel kind of
changing the rules of time travel that
in years past marvel would have said no
no no this timeline would just keep
going the new reality that maury
mckagert wakes up in is a new is is like
a new timeline in of itself so you know
if you've got the first time warren
mctagger died that's timeline one the
second time she died timeline two third
time she died timeline three so on and
so forth but they never cease to exist
all those timelines keep going now by
all standards of measurement they might
as well not exist because there isn't
really in a readily available means for
the mutants to like hop from one
dimension to the next right from one
universe to the other other people can
right but the mutants are very much
self-contained so unless they absolutely
need the help of like doctor strange or
the fantastic four they won't really
like leave and go explore other
universes or anything along those lines
so while those doors aren't necessarily
padlocked in the most extreme they might
as well be as far as the mutant
population is concerned because with the
tools available to them they can't
readily jump from one universe to the
next and so that's kind of the crazy
thing is because at the end of the day
destiny ends up realizing that while
emma frost isn't going to necessarily
work with them she's not going to work
against them but she has brought things
that they can use to basically help
right things that they can use to kind
of work against professor x and more
mctaggart to a degree under the idea
that everything they're doing will
actually get the mutant population
killed and that's one of the funny
things that hickman really seems to be
hitting at here but doesn't really seem
to be explicitly saying is that say for
example where mctaggart would have died
right she'll be fine she'll live on
she'll continue on and then she'll
likely end up grabbing charles xavier
and magneto and they'll you know she'll
kind of tell them everything that was
going on but you know professor x will
read her mind he'll pass that
information on to magneto and they'll
essentially be all caught up for
everyone else sorry about your luck
right for the life that emma frost was
formed for herself here that's gone for
the life that anybody else is formed
here that's gone that in a lot of ways
they all seem to be pawns in the game
that that more mctaggart charles xavier
and magneto are playing and that's one
of the things really probably the
biggest thing that pisses off emma frost
more than anything else is that they
brought her in because they felt like
they had to not necessarily because they
wanted to and so basically this whole
situation kind of unfolds with uh more
mchager coming out of her safe house
which exists outside of gracoa itself
and once she emerges she's immediately
set upon by the forces of orcus and then
essentially whisked away now it's kind
of a crazy thing because once you
transition over to the orcis forge you
basically pick up with omega talking to
nimrod and this is where things get
interesting because what happens here is
that nimrod has already picked up on the
fact that omega is not supposed to be
here right that she's not part of this
timeline she's from somewhere else in
the time stream now this was like an
itch that i couldn't scratch because i
knew i wasn't crazy when i first started
reading this i was like okay i'm i'm for
the most part caught up on the x-men
there's a few things that i'm missing
here and there but for the most part i'm
caught up but how in the world did omega
go from the character that we last saw
to this character here what's going on
here and so what she basically reveals
is that she's from the future but the
future she comes from in all those
different timelines the mutant
population always wins and that's
something that jonathan hickman had
never actually specified if you go back
and you read house and powers of x that
more mctaggarts seem to come from it
from the perspective that like the
mutant population always loses but then
omega comes along and says the mutant
population always wins and so what it
looks like is they're coming from two
distinctly different sets of
circumstances in terms of how the mutant
machine and human war ends up unfolding
either that or one of them's lying one
of them's not telling the truth and so
because of this she basically explains
at least in her timeline how it all
unfolds and the various timelines that
she seems to have experienced now
whether or not she's in the same on the
same capacity as as mormie taggart isn't
really explained here i would argue
that's probably not the case but the
important thing here is that at some
point along the line the post-human race
right the children of the vault the ones
that we'd seen that story on where like
x-23 and sync and them had gone into the
vault and then like barely escape with
their lives and like x-23 i think was
the only one who made it out alive i
don't know which one lived but like
those people there so basically
hyper-evolved humans uh that they would
emerge from the vault the problem is
they would emerge too early and that
apocalypse would return from morocco and
basically slaughter them all and then a
war would break out between humanity and
the mutant population but the mutant
population would start to gain the upper
hand in a last-ditch effort to basically
win the human population would create
the signal program and then by extension
they would launch nimrod and that in
creating nemrod it just wasn't really as
powerful as they needed it to be because
at that point in time what had happened
is the mutant population was on the
verge of complete and total destruction
now there was a side project going on
which we'll talk about here in a second
but the mutant population was basically
on the verge of destruction and so what
would happen is that they would send
nimrod into the past with the hope that
it could destroy the mutant population
in its infancy something akin to like
skynet and terminator right like
basically what they were shooting for
here but that nimrod would always fail
now here's the funny thing about this
right if you go and you read
new x-men vol 2 there's a four-part
story called nimrod and for years and
years and years people would debate
whether or not that version of nimrod
that was fought in new mutants vol 2 was
the same nimrod or like a against the
version of nimrod that returned from
like the old school days right from the
days of future past universe that went
into the past and then basically merged
with uh master mold in the siege
perilous and then went on to become
bastion what hickman seem to be doing
here is saying no that version of nimrod
they fought in uh in new mutants volume
2. that's this guy it's this guy and
he's arriving in the past from this
present here right from this future so i
don't know if that's true he doesn't
really say although we're really told is
that that version of nimrod goes into
the past and then is ultimately
destroyed right so again we're not
really given a definitive answer but i
feel like it'd be a very nice and
elegant way to kind of answer that
question that has really been plaguing
the fan base since like the mid 2000s
but ultimately what would happen is that
you would have humanity which would
merge with machine technology kind of
creating like the new post humans and
that in doing so they would begin to
gain the upper hand on the mutant
population the problem with this is the
mutant population had cosmic powers at
their disposal more specifically the
blade of the phoenix now the blade of
the phoenix is a sword that can only be
wielded by rookshear brookshire of
course being a member of the shiar
empire and if you guys recall what we've
seen so far especially at the beginning
of new mutants as part of uh the dawn of
x line is that the mutant population
formed an alliance with the shia empire
right now rook shear himself was
actually a member of the shia who ended
up basically gaining the gaining access
or was a host for the phoenix force the
phoenix blade can only be wielded by the
descendants of rookshare right like his
direct family line people who share his
blood anybody else who tries to pick it
up will either be destroyed by it or
it'll just be a random sword but they'll
never be able to use it in the same
capacity using the full totality of what
it can do with its small shard of the
phoenix which is imbued to the sword but
in this future during this war between
uh basically the post-human race the the
the human machine hybrid race and the
mutant population that where the mutant
population found itself on the verge of
being destroyed that what would happen
is that post-humanity would basically
draw the attention of the phalanx race
right that race out there that basically
is kind of like this super advanced
machine race that would achieve higher
states of power and they would literally
travel around the universe after
seemingly absorbing the cosmic entities
and then in turn start like turning
various worlds to their cost but once a
planet had achieved a higher level of
technological development that the
phalanx would see them as worth
assimilating into their race and the
phalanx would arrive on earth because of
the the attempt of the human machine
hybrid to draw the attention of the
phalanx in the hope that one the phalanx
would destroy what was left of the
mutant population because they wouldn't
see them as being worth merging with and
two that the the post-human race would
find this kind of perfection by being
merged with the faint links race itself
what would actually happen in these
timelines at least in terms of omega's
understanding of it is that using the
phoenix blade this sort of looks here
that the mutant population would
actually destroy these these phalanx
individuals as they arrived on earth
they would wipe them out and because of
the fact that they were using what was
in effect godly technology there was
nothing the post-human race could do so
they would die off as well and in the
end that's how the mutant population
would reign supreme that's how they
would dominate everything now in order
to keep that from happening which is a
very reminiscent scenario from days of
future past is that omega's
consciousness was basically sent into
the past into this body for the purpose
of allowing her to basically warn the
human population to ensure that humans
could come out on top so that's what
really kind of blew my mind on this is
that in the original days of future past
timeline it was the sentinels that
conquered north america and then
eventually the world and so basically
humans and mutants were subjugated by
the sentinel population and the
sentinels basically ended up just kind
of going awry just continuing on and
then seemingly dominating everything
what this is is basically the antithesis
that as far as omega is concerned this
is essentially days of future past
except it's humans and they're merging
with machine technology becoming
post-humans that are essentially
subjugated and eventually destroyed by
the mutant population and the mutants
went out and so much like the original
days of future past her mind is sent to
the past to keep this from happening the
way kitty pride warned the mutant
population that the assassination of
senator mora mctaggart uh robert kelly
and and professor xavier would lead to
the launching or the the return of the
sentinel program under stephen lang and
eventually days of future past omega's
here to warn the human population of the
mutant's impending victory she's kind of
working quietly behind the scenes that
dr killian devo was initially just a guy
who was out there but what ended up
happening is that omega actually
developed what were essentially
mind-altering glasses that led him to
believe that he lived this life
alongside her and maybe he did right
maybe he actually did we're not fully
told that's the case but basically he
ended up seeing the destruction of the
human population and that's why orcis
and all this is being done is to ensure
their own survival and it's and it's
crazy because from what from here what
you do is you actually transition to
terra verde that basically that's where
maura mctaggart was taken when she was
kidnapped by orcas and that uh mystique
and destiny were seemingly given this
information by emma frost and that what
happens is when they arrive on the scene
that it looks as though more mctaggart
has either been defeated or killed but
one way or another is kind of hard to
tell you basically end up having destiny
and mystique who were at this location
that seemed to be basically tormenting
uh mora mctaggart again we're not really
sure if she is dead now like literally
you kind of have those moments when
she's seemingly being tortured by
mystique and destiny so of course she
seems alive at that moment that when you
have xavier and magneto walk in like her
arms just sitting there in a chair so it
looks like they did just lop her arm off
and now they just got her in some other
location and that's basically it but a
trap has effectively been set because
when when xavier and magneto walk in
here suddenly the teleportation portal
starts activating and when it does you
get a whole bunch of foot soldiers
coming in and then you get nimrod but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you guys for
watching
and i will catch you all later
peace